Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie, bet you didn't
think we were going to get a Supergirl crossover
this early.
So I'm going to explain what's going on there
is the Supergirl crossover stuff.
There's a flash arrow crossover there's black
flash stuff and they tease future flash on
legends of tomorrow.
So I tried to include all that in this video,
but there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
This is really the top seven, but I did it
as a top five so there's like two extra things
at the end of this about black flash legends
of tomorrow stuff whole bunch of stuff going
on here, but starting with number five the
Supergirl crossover, you may have spotted
that there in Cat Grants office here fighting
Cisco in his full vibe costume and Gypsy.
So the reason for that is probably because
they both have the ability to vibe across
dimensions.
So during this epic gypsy versus Vibe battle.
It looks like they'll just be battling each
other through different dimensions.
At least this one may be others to that's
the really exciting thing is that when they
have really quick moments like this you can
tease other dimensions that we haven't seen
yet.
Like we can get a better look at earth.
19 they can tease earth two for the big gorilla
city episode that's going to be episodes 13
and 14.
Saul mentioned something about that again
at the end of the video.
That's why it's so important to look at what's
going on in the background when they have
big montages like this sometimes you just
have to watch a couple times or however you
watch the video just like rewind it if you
streaming it from the CW app if you having
trouble finding the show don't put it on Hulu
anymore in the United States.
You have to go to the CW app to watch it or
you can go to the CW website, but hopefully
whichever country you live in your able to
find it the night that it airs you not to
wait too long, but there's a big blast Supergirl
crossover coming in episode 17, they just
tease that I'll do a separate video for that
eventually, but it's a little ways up it's
the music Meister Episode Is Gonna Take place
in Central city but they haven't explained
how they're getting all the Supergirl characters,
on to Earth one.
So they'll be a separate video but number
four is flash arrow crossover in the same
vein, is this really quick Supergirl crossover.
So next week on arrow is going to be the quickest
flash crossover that you've ever seen like
don't blink or you'll miss it.
But they haven't explain what it's gonna be
is just this picture of the flash, and Captain
Singh's office in Central city so it sounds
like Barry is going to help get them some
information.
Maybe it has something to do with the new
black canary or with black siren.
Because they haven't addressed whether or
not she escaped on the flash yet, so hopefully
they'll be a moment like that and next week's
episode number three Dr. alchemy on the team
in a sort of like a funny twos accompanied
three is a crowd funny moments were he's like
there's like seven things here.
You could've done way better than you did
them in everyone else was like well you know
Julie about this is good.
So there's gonna be a lot of funny moment
with Julian butting into the team trying to
make them better.
It was that funny moment at the end the last
week's episode, where he had that really awkward
comment Caitlin's I will work on your personal
skills so by the end of the season.
He'll probably chill a little bit just in
the way that HR has chilled out to his chest
is I think a lot of us to live.
A lot of us have a tough trip in Houston Texans
show number two Iris telling Barry that she
doesn't want to hide away for the rest of
the season just because they think that she's
destined to die.
So in case you forgot because they haven't
done it in a while.
She's a news reporter she looks like she's
out trying to solve the case Jeevan steps
up to this person's gun barrel.
So this is them telling you that Iris is going
to get a storyline that has nothing to do
with her avoiding trying to get because it.
What would happen if you knew you were going
to die you go hide in a bunker for like the
next three months.
This is them showing you that that's not can
happen is that you can be doing some interesting
stuff you see Wally basking in the adoration
of all these cheerleaders that look like they're
dressed in the small Ville cheerleading costumes
that I should look like they pulled them from
the small Ville archives and that's all Warner
Bros. stuff, so they can reuse props from
small Ville.
If you've ever thought that you saw something
that looked like it was from small though,
it probably was because that was another Vancouver
show in the flesh shoots in Vancouver in the
number one big thing is this teaser for legends
of tomorrow Barry might guest star in episode
16.
Marc Guggenheim teased in this is him I'm
quoting him.
He says in the penultimate episode were going
to have.
I can't be specific about this, but it's one
of the most fun things I think we've ever
done on the show a character from one of our
other shows on legends in a way that you've
never seen them before.
This could be any number of things.
But it's gonna be a really comic book he moment
where it's from like an alternate future something
like that, because remember the Legion of
doom has the Spear of destiny.
So people are thinking that they'll get it
change history in some way before the legends
fix it, and will get a look at somebody in
a different context and because we have this
big Barry Allen from 2056 message might actually
pay that off, and we'll see him from that
timeline.
And it'll be like the future version of the
flash from this darkest timeline or just like
a really fun wink at that.
The way they word that makes it sound like
it someone who hasn't already done some alternate
version of himself on legends, so I don't
think that it's going to be a future version
of Oliver wear has like the beard and the
one arm, they've already done that.
I think it's much more likely that it would
be a flash thing or it would be a Jay Garrick
thing.
And it'll be just a society stuff.
But they didn't say what.
The twist was that would cause this alternate
version of a character the we note to show
up hidden safe.
It would be the Spear of destiny that would
create a new version them or if it would be
from our own timeline, but you guys can let
me know who do you think this mystery character
that's going to be this really crazy.
We get the fans in super comic book he is
going to be he said they just gave the actor
the offer.
So this is somebody who's probably a series
regular on the flash arrow or Supergirl yet
to consider Supergirl as well if it is someone
from Supergirl.
I would expect that it be valor with his full
comic book costume any be with.
The Legion of superheroes in the 31st century
if you like that far in the future but I'm
really hoping we get to see a future version
of Barry Allen in a very different costume.
Because, based on the behind-the-scenes stuff
Barry's costume has not changed on the flash
yet but it could be any number of people just
expected to be a really big deal.
Even though it's gonna be a one-off thing
the other really big thing to is the black
flash that's going to be coming to the flash
very soon it also to legends of tomorrow in
the last couple of episodes I think it's episode
15 of legends of tomorrow.
They did confirm that he be coming for eobard
Thawne.
So do a separate video about that for legends
when we get a little bit closer next video
tonight will be a video for all the trailers
that are gonna be dropping at the Super Bowl.
There's a whole bunch of stuff while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here to
catch up on the flash and you can click here
for my Snoke episode 8 video.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you in the next video!